so Cherie I wanted to ask you a couple
questions because there's a lot of talk
about Goldman Sachs government sacks
what's the story here we'll get to that
but probably it does not include these
vests do you agree all right let's take
them off thanks
so there's this Goldman Sachs Network in
the government it seems how deep is it
and why does it even exist the reason
we're talking about it right now is of
course the elevation of Rishi sunak as
the new prime minister in the UK going
back to 2005 we've not had more than two
days when a Goldman Sachs executive has
not held a position of power in the G7
countries where either one of them is
either a premier a central bank Governor
or a finance minister do people join
Goldman Sachs with the intention of
going on to work for governments later
on people join Goldman Sachs to be
really successful at Goldman Sachs and
make a lot of money but once you're
successful at Goldman Sachs and once
you've reached that position of
influence a lot of opportunities open up
for you you'll automatically seen as a
contender maybe for running a company
maybe running a hedge fund also being in
a position of power in government this
idea of this Goldman Network what's the
story behind it oh fun fact that goes
back to more than a century back in 1913
when they were looking to set up the
Federal Reserve Henry Goldman the son of
Marcus Goldman the founder of Goldman
Sachs actually lobbied Woodrow Wilson to
help pass the Federal Reserve Act that
led to the creation of the U.S Central
Bank after that year Sydney Weinberg the
long-term chief of Goldman Sachs Bob
Rubin and the Clinton Administration so
this is not a conspiracy theory it's
actual history it's for the longest time
if you were a senior partner at Goldman
Sachs you were expected to join
government you were ex you was seen as
public service
[Music]